hola de nuevo en este vídeo quiero que
analicemos y además discutamos un poco
la idea de rentar de rentar rentar
contra comprar una casa contra comprar
una casa
comprar ok y bueno lo primero que quiero
decirte es que no es una respuesta
sencilla sobre si siempre es mejor
rentar o si siempre es mejor comprar una
casa eso depende claro en cierta forma
de una parte emocional o una parte
potencialmente económica o en qué
momento de la vida estés aunque el lugar
del planeta vivas y cómo se comporte su
economía es decir de cómo están las
rentas contra cómo están después la casa
de varios factores en este vídeo yo no
quiero convencer a nadie sobre qué es
mejor si rentar o comprar una casa lo
que quiero es que entremos en un
análisis de esta situación y tal vez te
sirva a ti para que tú tomes una
decisión pero bueno supongamos que esta
es la casa que tú quieres rentar o
comprar y esta casa que tenemos aquí
vamos a suponer que es la casa de tus
sueños y esta casa tiene dos opciones la
primera es que se esté rentando y vamos
a suponer que este es tarde a 1500 pesos
1500 pesos por mes por mes ok y bueno
1500 pesos por mes esto quiere decir que
en un año pagaríamos 18 mil pesos en un
año pagaríamos 18 mil 18 mil pesos por
año por año de lujo esto en el dado caso
de rentar pero también vamos a suponer
que esta misma casa se puede vender la
están vendiendo y el precio de venta de
la casa es de 400 mil pesos así que lo
voy a poner aquí el precio es de 400 mil
400 mil pesos ok y supongamos que tú no
tienes esa cantidad de dinero y lo único
que tienes es lo que has ahorrado
durante toda tu vida que son 100 mil
pesos los cuales los vas a dar de
enganche entonces voy a poner aquí a 100
mil pesos 100 mil pesos 100 mil pesos es
lo que hace ahorrado y es lo que vas a
dar te engancha el depósito para poder
comprarla voy a ponerle aquí el gancho
ok
y bueno si este es el enganche date
cuenta que la diferencia entre 400.000
pesos y 100 mil pesos es lo que tú vas a
necesitar pedir al banco prestado para
que tú puedas comprar esta casa así que
si me tomo la diferencia a 300 mil pesos
300 mil pesos va a ser lo que vas a
pedir prestado al banco entonces este va
a ser el préstamo
préstamo préstamo ok ahora si pensamos
en una hipoteca tradicional no sé se me
ocurre pensar en una hipoteca fija a 15
años o una hipoteca fija a 30 años en
una hipoteca tradicional ocurre más o
menos lo siguiente si tú te fijas en la
cuota que vas a pagar mensualmente lo
que ocurre es que si tú tienes aquí la
cantidad que vas a pagar tú mensualmente
supongamos que es esta en una hipoteca
tradicional lo que ocurre es que
normalmente una cierta parte se va a
pagar el interés y otras cierta parte se
va a pagar la deuda y si nosotros
suponemos no sé qué es lo que vas a
pagar son mil ochocientos pesos por mes
mil ochocientos pesos por mes bueno en
una hipoteca tradicional en un principio
la mayor parte de este dinero se va a
destinar a pagar el interés entonces voy
a poner aquí en interés
interés
interés de estos mil 800 pesos que vas a
pagar al mes bueno tal vez en un
principio mil quinientos pesos mil
quinientos pesos se destina el interés
mientras que el resto que son
trescientos 300 se va a destinar a bajar
este préstamo entonces lo voy a poner
está muy ok esto es lo que ocurre en una
hipoteca tradicional y después va
transcurriendo el tiempo hasta que llega
un punto en el que pasa justo lo
contrario déjame poner aquí el
rectángulo que represente lo que vas a
pagar así que voy a intentar hacerlo lo
más
adecuado posible un rectángulo más o
menos así ok y bueno después de que pase
el tiempo va a pasar justo lo contrario
va a llegar un punto en el que tú vas a
pagar mucho más del préstamo porque el
préstamo ha ido bajando préstamo
entonces supongamos que pagas a 1500
pesos del préstamo ok y después
solamente vas a pagar 300 pesos de
interés por qué date cuenta que estás
pagando mucho el préstamo y entonces el
préstamo se ha reducido lo suficiente
entonces vas a pagar 300 pesos de
interés
es de lujo ahora para simplificar un
poco todos estas cuentas que vamos a ser
justo ahorita voy a suponer que el
interés es fijo es decir que si tu pie
es un cierto préstamo de la cantidad que
te van a cobrar al mes va a ser muy
clara la cantidad que se va a ir al
préstamo y la cantidad que se va a ir al
interés tú vas a tener una gran cantidad
en la cual vas a poder reducir tu
préstamo y vas a tener una cierta
cantidad que va a pagar el interés por
este préstamo generado y bueno no
forzosamente tiene que ser esta
proporción de hecho creo que va a ser
una proporción un poco mejor así que
vamos a ponerlo vamos a suponer que
solamente pagamos un cierto interés
vamos a ponerle un interés y te ves solo
solo al al
6% al 6% ok voy a suponer que el interés
es solamente al 6 por ciento del
préstamo total y bueno si quisiéramos
hacer un detalle mucho más extenso
podríamos analizar qué es lo que pasa a
través del tiempo con el préstamo y con
el interés pero para ahorita que se
hagan las cosas mucho más fácil voy a
suponer que el interés sólo está al 6% y
bueno si calculamos el 6% de 300.000
entonces voy a decir que el interés de
interés al año voy a pagar el 6% de
300.000 lo cual son 18 mil
18 mil pesos esto es lo que voy a pagar
de interés
interés ahora dependiendo donde vivas y
cuál es tu nivel de ingresos en algunos
lugares tú puedes deducir el interés de
tu deuda de tus ingresos depende del
lugar pero vamos a suponer que si tú
ganas no sea 100 mil pesos al año
tú puedes deducir de tus impuestos
bueno puede hacer la diferencia de 100
mil pesos menos 18 mil pesos y en
general vamos a hacer que de una manera
sencilla tú puedas deducir un tercio de
esta cantidad de interés es decir a esto
le voy a quitar a seis mil pesos seis
mil pesos que es lo que voy a suponer
que vamos a poder deducir de nuestros
impuestos es decir va a reducir a
reducir reducir los impuestos impuestos
ok y bueno esto quiere decir que si
contamos que vamos a poder deducir una
cierta cantidad de dinero en los
impuestos entonces cuando yo me tomé la
diferencia de estos dos voy a decir que
el costo efectivo del interés es am me
quedó 12 mil pesos 12 mil pesos es el
costo costo efectivo efectivo del
interés del interés
interés
también depende de dónde vivas pero en
muchas partes del mundo uno tiene que
pagar un cierto impuesto por tener una
casa en su propiedad entonces vamos a
suponer que en esta situación tú tienes
que pagar am se me ocurre un 1 por
ciento del valor de la casa un 1 por
ciento de 400.000 de impuestos por ser
el propietario de esta casa entonces a
esto le voy a agregar le voy a agregar 4
mil 4 mil pesos que va a ser el impuesto
por pagar esta casa entonces
vamos a sumar esto pero aquí voy a poner
que es el impuesto
impuesto de de propiedad de
propiedad
propiedad ok y en este caso si sumamos
otros 4000 voy a obtener 16 mil pesos 16
mil pesos que es lo que tengo que pagar
extra 16 mil pesos por año para ello
obtener esta casa que tengo aquí ahora a
estos 16 mil pesos yo quiero agregarle
algo que no hemos contado supongamos que
necesitamos a un jardinero para que para
que mantenga estos jardines super
frescos o tal vez necesites pintura para
que la casa quede muy muy padre o tal
vez necesites no sé alguna reparación
entonces voy a suponer que en un año
completo tú te gastas otros dos mil
pesos otros dos mil pesos en
reparaciones dos mil pesos en
reparaciones
oraciones y mantenimiento de la casa
reparación y mantenimiento ante cni
miento ok y estoy suponiendo esto porque
si te das cuenta cuando rentas realmente
no tienes que pagar esto la reparación y
el mantenimiento deben de incluirse en
la renta por lo tanto si yo agrego a 16
mil otros dos mil voy a llegar a 18 mil
pesos 18 mil pesos por año por año ok
ahora lo que quiero que te des cuenta es
que si tu rentas una casa se van por la
puerta 18 mil pesos por año mientras que
si tú compras una casa se va a ir por la
puerta 18 mil pesos también por año y
ojo esto lo estoy diciendo según las
hipótesis que estamos tratando de si las
hipótesis cambian bueno tal vez cambie a
lo que va a salir rentar una casa o tal
vez cambie a lo que salga en comprar una
casa dada las hipótesis que estamos
suponiendo justo ahorita puedo decir que
por la puerta en un año cuando rentó una
casa se me van 18 mil pesos por año
mientras que si compro la casa por la
puerta también se me van a ir 18 mil
pesos por año que tienen que haber 12
mil del costo efectivo de interés 12 mil
del costo efectivo de interés 4 mil del
impuesto de la propiedad 4 mil del
impuesto de la propiedad y otros 2 mil
por el mantenimiento suman 18 mil pesos
por año es decir que tanto rentando como
comprando una casa la cantidad de dinero
que se va a ir por la puerta es decir la
cantidad de dinero que vamos a perder es
hasta ahorita exactamente la misma ahora
aquí hay algo que todavía estamos
olvidando si te das cuenta aquí gastamos
esos 100 mil pesos que tenemos ahorros
dando el enganche de la casa sin embargo
si rentamos la casa seguimos teniendo
estos 100 mil pesos de ahorros así que
los voy a poner aquí tengo 100 mil pesos
100 mil pesos de ahorros de toda mi vida
ok ahora quiero que te des cuenta que
estos 100 mil pesos que es mi ahorros de
toda la vida puedo hacer algo con ellos
no sé tal vez puedo invertirlos en el
banco o invertirlos en un portafolio o
usarlos para una inversión en alto
riesgo qué sé yo pero bueno supongamos
que lo que estoy haciendo es simple y
sencillamente invertirlos en el banco y
si yo estoy dando una inversión en el
banco supongamos que y eso depende de
cada banco y depende de cada región
vamos a suponer para no complicarnos la
vida que me dan no sé un 12 por ciento
voy a suponer un 2% de ingreso o de la
tasa de ingresos por esta cantidad que
ahorro entonces déjame ponerlo aquí
vamos a suponer que tengo un 2 por
ciento un dos por ciento de ganancia por
esta inversión un 2% por la inversión de
este dinero algo voy a estar haciendo
con este ahorro ok y si te das cuenta el
2% de 100 mil esto es lo mismo que dos
mil dos mil pesos dos mil pesos van a
ser mi ingreso por la inversión mi
ingreso
ingreso por inversión por
inversión ok ahora si te das cuenta aquí
tengo dos mil pesos más de ingreso lo
que quiere decir que no se me van a ir
18 mil pesos por la puerta en un año
puedo rescatar dos mil pesos por este
ingreso por inversión visto de otra
manera puedo decir que estos dos mil
pesos los puedo utilizar pagando la
renta de esta casa y entonces voy a
decir que tal vez solamente 16 mil pesos
16 mil pesos son los que se muevan por
son los que pierdo por año al rentar una
casa por
ok esto gracias a que tengo dos mil
pesos de ingresos por inversión y bueno
parece ser que hasta aquí
me conviene de una manera económica más
en rentar rentar una casa que comprarla
si te das cuenta aquí tengo 16 mil veces
por año mientras que aquí tengo 18 mil
pesos por año y bueno si quiero aclarar
que esto depende de cómo cambian los
números qué tal si me dan un poco menos
de inversión bueno entonces eso no sería
tan bueno para mí en mi renta por un año
o qué tal es mi renta aumenta no lo sé o
podría pensar que tal vez el interés que
voy a pagarle al banco cuando yo quiera
comprar una casa no sea del 6% tal vez
sea menor o tal vez sea mayor y tal vez
se reduce el impuesto tal vez una
cantidad mayor según donde esté en la
zona o tal vez el costo efectivo del
interés sea distinto o el impuesto por
la propiedad cambie o la reparación no
tengamos mucha reparación de esta casa
qué sé yo a lo que voy es que hasta
ahorita con las cuentas como las he
hecho
una manera sencilla parece ser mejor
rentar que comprar una casa de una
manera económica ojo depende de los
números tú intenta hacer tus propios
números para ver qué es lo que te
conviene más rentar o comprar ahora
seguramente en este momento me vas a
decir bueno es que aquí en la cantidad
que yo estoy pagando al mes estoy
ahorrando o estoy salvando algo de
dinero si te das cuenta aquí tengo 300
pesos los cuales están yendo a pagar
este préstamo ahora yo te puedo decir
que si mi renta es de 1.500 por mes y me
van a cobrar por comprar una casa mil
800 pesos al mes pues bien podría
ahorrar estos 300 pesos que hay de
diferencia y meterlos mes por mes
durante los 30 años que me van a cobrar
el interés para que yo logre pagar este
préstamo a esta cuenta de ahorros y te
lo juro que después de un cierto tiempo
vamos a tener una gran cantidad de
dinero ahorrado si logro meter estos 300
pesos aquí a mi cuenta de ahorros así
que creo que no es una respuesta fácil
decir si renta mejor que comprar o
comprar es mejor que rentar eso depende
ahora todo lo que hemos visto hasta
ahorita es de una manera completamente
económica ahora también hay otras cosas
que nos podrían ayudar a tomar esta
decisión y justo ahorita quiero ver los
pros y los contras de rentar contra
comprar una casa así que para esto
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla porque
ya no tenemos espacio déjenme bajar un
poco la pantalla voy a despedir un poco
a esta casa porque aquí voy a poner los
pros y los contras aún déjenme ponerle
aquí los pros y los contras de rentar de
rentar
contra comprar una casa rentar
y aquí comprar comprar y vamos a
analizar los pros y los contras que no
sean económicos de estas dos opciones
ahora el primer pro que yo le veo a
comprar una casa y seguramente por eso
se te antoja comprar una casa es porque
comprar una casa te da estabilidad
es decir ya tienes un patrimonio si tu
renta es una casa aunque tal vez seas el
vecino perfecto y tal vez te lleves muy
bien con la persona que te renta en
cualquier momento la persona que te
renta puede decidir rentar sela a otra
persona o en su dado caso tal vez él
quiera moverse a esa casa y por lo tanto
tú vas a tener que moverte de ahí ahora
cuando tú compras una casa decides pagar
todo esto porque estás pensando en tu
patrimonio en tu estabilidad y que al
final es tu casa y nadie te va a mover
de ahí otra idea correcta que se me
ocurre para comprar una casa sería que
las rentas pueden aumentar déjame
ponerlo aquí las rentas las rentas
pueden aumentar pueden aumentar
menta es decir tal vez en el lugar en el
que está rentando aumentes la renta
porque la demanda de la casa en la que
estás viviendo aumente no sé tal vez
haya zonas como por ejemplo en la
capital de tu país o tal vez alguna zona
turística en donde si la casa está ahí
la renta puede aumentar de precio
depende mucho de la demanda y del lugar
en donde esté posicionada la casa que
quieres rentar
ahora otra idea que se me ocurre es que
cuando tú compras una casa puedes hacer
mejoras hacer hacer mejoras mejoras y
bueno esto me pasó bastante con mi
familia porque cuando yo quería comprar
una casa vi un montón de casas y muchas
de ellas podías cambiarles el color de
la pared cuando tú las comprabas o hacer
un nuevo estudio no sé lo que a ti se te
ocurra tú puedes hacer tu casa como tú
quieras y entonces cuando tú compras una
casa tú decides qué es lo que quieres en
tu casa ahora estos son los pros o las
cosas buenas que se me ocurren cuando tú
quieras comprar una casa cuando tú
quieres rentar una casa también hay
cosas buenas y la primera que se me
ocurre y la que más me gusta es la
flexibilidad lee o espera esta es una r
flexi
es decir que en cualquier momento si a
ti no te caen bien tus vecinos o tal vez
tú tengas que irte a otro estado a
trabajar o tal vez tú quieras cambiar de
aires tú puedes dejar esa casa en la que
estás e ir a rentar otra casa en donde
tú quieras cuando tú rentas una casa la
flexibilidad te ayuda bastante a que tú
puedes cambiar el lugar en donde estás
viviendo por un lugar que sea como demás
a lo que tú quieres la flexibilidad yo
creo que ayuda bastante y es un gran
punto a favor porque por ejemplo puedes
tener la libertad de no estar apegado a
tu casa que acabas de comprar y entonces
puedes buscar tal vez un empleo si
quedas desempleado en algún otro sitio
sin la necesidad de tener que vender tu
casa y bueno otro punto bueno al que yo
le veo a diferencia de comprar es que
comprar hay veces que es demasiado caro
lo voy a poner aquí a las casas las
casas
muy caras muy caras y bueno lo estoy
viendo desde un punto económico justo
aquí o también lo puedo decir como que
el precio de la casa aumente aunque
realmente no sea su precio original
podemos decir que comprar es un poco más
caro que rentar y bueno tal vez en los
siguientes vídeos analice con más calma
todo esto que tengo que ver aquí y te dé
algunos ejemplos donde en definitiva
comprar no es la mejor opción pero lo
que quiero que te des cuenta es que aquí
está el panorama sobre la interrogante
de qué es mejor si rentar o comprar una
casa y quiero que te des cuenta que no
es un tema nada fácil pero espero que
todo este vídeo te haya ayudado a que
tengas una opinión ya que puedas tomar
su decisión sobre rentar o comprar una
casa